[Applause]  nope he's gonna play it out i like it  on the road mcclung for the win oh my  goodness  matt mcclung with 2.2 left  you will not find a bigger three-pointer  made in big 12 play  you know what i love about that rich i  second-guess myself  i thought chris beard was going to take  the time out look at him he's got he  said mac take it  take it end it  we talked to chris beard we talked to  him yesterday  this was a great moment and a great team  man this is a real good team we just  played  all right max so you got color edwards  you got tj out there and it's you  chris beer said give it to mac what's  that feeling like in terms of the  confidence  my teammates are telling me i got to go  i respect you a lot friend you're the  man  but i gotta go celebrate man you go we  got you  sir noah blows off fran for sure  but you know what we're  that is how much a road win means oh  yeah